how does memory emerge how does which is
this how does this the temporal
stickiness
so objects emerge
um
i i i i'm gonna take a very chemocentric
point of view because i can't imagine
any other way of doing it you you could
think of other ways maybe
but i would say
heterogeneity in matter
is where the memory so you must have
enough different ways of rearranging
matter for there to be a memory so what
that means is if you've got particles
colliding in a box let's just take a
uh some in or some elements in a box
those elements can combine in a
combinatorial set of ways so there's a
commentary explosion of the number of
molecules or minerals or solid objects
bonds being made
because there's such a large number the
population of different objects that are
possible this goes back to assembly
theory where assembly theory there's
four types of universes right so you've
got basically a um and this is what one
was up earlier where
one universe where you've just got
everything is possible so you can take
all the atoms and combine them and make
everything
then you've got basically
what is the assembly combinatorial where
you basically have to accrue information
in steps
then you've got um assembly observed
right and then you've got the object
assembly going back so what that mean
what i'm trying to say is like if you
can take atoms and make bonds let's say
you take a nitrogen atom and add it to a
carbon atom you find an amino acid then
you add another carbon atom in a
particular configuration then another
one all different molecules they all
represent different histories
so i would say for me right now the most
simple route into life seems to be
through recording memories and chemistry
but that doesn't mean there can't be
other ways and can't be other emergent
effects
but i think if you can make bonds and
lots of different bonds
and they those molecules can have a
causal effect on the future so imagine a
box of atoms
then then you combine those atoms in
some way so you make molecule
a
from load of atoms and then molecule a
can go back to the box
and influence the box
then you make
a prime or a b or abc and that process
keeps going and that's where the
memories come from is that heterogeneity
in the universe from bonding
i don't know if that makes anything and
it's
beginning to flourish
at the chemistry level
yeah so the physicists have no no
no like not enough yeah the phys i mean
they're like desperately begging well
the physicist will claim freedom yeah uh
and heterogeneous
components to play with yeah
that's exactly it what do you think
about that sir
i mentioned already i think it's
significant that whatever physics
governs life emerges actually in
chemistry it's not relevant at the
subatomic scale or
even at the atomic scale it's in
well atomic scale because chemistry but
like when you get into this this
combinatorial diversity that you get
from combining things on the periodic
table that's when
selection actually matters or the fact
that some things can exist and others
can't exist actually starts to matter
so i think of it like
you don't you don't study gravity inside
the atomic nucleus you study it in terms
of large scale structure of the universe
or black holes or things like that and
whatever we're talking about as physics
of information or physics of assembly
becomes relevant at a certain scale of
reality
and
and the transition that you're talking
about i would think of is just when you
get a sufficient density
in terms of the assembly space of like
the relationship of the overlap and and
the assembly space which is like a
feature of common memory there is this
transition um to assembly dominated
physics whatever that is
oh like when we're talking about and
we're trying to map out exactly what
that transition looks like we're pretty
sure
you know of some of its features but we
haven't done all of that do you think if
you were there in the early universe you
would have been able to predict the
emergence of chemistry and biology and i
asked that because at this stage as
humans do you think we can possibly
predict
the length of memory that's that might
be able to be formed
later on
in this pocket of the universe like how
how complex
is uh what is the ceiling of assembly
i think as much time as you have in the
past is how much you can predict in the
future because that it's actually
physical in the system and you have to
have enough time for
uh
features of that structure to exist
wait let me push back in that way
isn't that isn't there somewhere in the
universe that's like a shortest path
that's been that stretches all the way
to the beginning yeah that's building
some giant monster
maybe yeah yes
the universe has as much memory as the
largest assembly object in the universe
yeah right but like so you can't predict
you can't predict any deeper than that
no right so like that i guess that's all
i'm saying is
like what intuition do you have about
complexity living in the world that
you'd have today
right because you you just you can i
mean i guess how long
um
does it get more fun like isn't there
going to be at some point because
there's a there's a heat death in the
universe isn't it
going to be a point of the most
of the highest assembly of object
with the highest probability being
generated when is the universe going to
be the most fun and can we freeze
ourselves and then live then exactly
and will you know when you're having the
most fun that this is the best time
you're in your prime are you going to do
what everyone does which is deny that
you're in your prime and the best years
are still ahead of you
i don't know what option do you have um
uh
i i i mean the problem is with there's a
lot of lots of really interesting
features here i just want to mention one
thing that might be is i do think
assembly theory applies all the way back
to subatomic particles and i also think
that cosmological selection might have
been actually there there might have
been a i would say it's a really boring
bit but it's really important for a
cosmologist that the universes have gone
through was it lee smolin who proposed
this maybe that there is this the basic
universe evolves you've got the wrong
constants we'll start again and the most
productive constants where you can allow
particles to form in a certain way get
propagated to the next universe we go
again so actually selection goes all the
way back and there's this cycle of
universes and now this universe has been
selected because
um life can occur and it carries on
you